hello everybody and welcome to this
tutorial on a new opportunity to come
and work for the EU institutions
today we're looking to select
specialists in the fields of Safety and
Security
on our website you may have seen this
infographic which gives you a short
overview of the different steps of this
competition and today I will explain to
you a bit more in detail what these
different steps entail
it is an AST tree level competition
which means that you need relevant
post-secondary education and a number of
years of relevant professional
experience into one of the fields of
this competition
or you need secondary Education Plus
even more years of relevant experience
now first of all there are three fields
in this competition as you notice on
this Slide the field of operational
security
the field of technical security and the
field of occupational health and safety
and you see the numbers of successful
candidates that we are going to select
through these competitions
you can apply for one field only
and the relevance of your post-secondary
education and your secondary education
differs or varies per field for which
you want to apply and this is well
explained in the notice of competition
so please do have a look to this notice
of competition which we have published
on on the website now and you will find
the details there for instance for field
one operational security
you see on this Slide the the types of
the diploma the minimum length of the
education you have followed and then the
subsequent a minimum length of
experience you need if you have this or
other type of diploma
same for the second field technical
security you see a list of diplomas
accepted into this competition you see
the duration again of the education you
must have followed and the the
professional experience which goes with
the diploma
so it's very detailed it's very specific
so please have a careful look at these
different tables which you will find in
the notes of competition which gives you
a clear idea whether or not you are
eligible for one or other field
the second criteria to take part in this
competition apart from the diploma and
relevant experience is of course always
the language Criterium
you need to speak at least two EU
languages
language one can be one of the 24
official evil languages you must Master
this language on level C1 minimum and
your second language must be either
English or French up to you to choose
and your knowledge must be at least at
level B2
the structure of this competition
follows the regular path so you have to
first apply of course everybody who
applies will be invited to a first stage
of testing which is a set of reasoning
skills and then the best ones will be
invited to the second stage which is an
assessment center where we test General
and field specific competencies
again the best ones after stage two will
be the successful ones who will then be
recruited by the different EU bodies
let's have a closer look at these
different stages of the competition
everything starts of course with the
creation of an episode account if you
already have an episode account do not
create a second one you can only have
one episode account which you can use
for all your applications that you want
to sit with us if you don't have one yet
you can easily create one through our
website
once you have an account you can apply
to this competition again through our
website you will find this opportunity
on the home page of the e-careers
website you simply click through you you
choose a field and you can fill out your
application
you can fill it out in any of the 24
official languages and you should
validate your application at the latest
on the 20th of December noon Brussels
time so between today and the day of
closing of this application period you
can go in and out of your application
your changes are saved
once you progress in your application
but you must as I said validate it by
the 20th of December
everybody who validates his application
his or her application on the day of
closing will be invited to the first
stage of testing which is I said this
set of reasoning skills
we test your verbal numerical and
abstract reasoning skills
in your language one so one of the 24
languages of the EU you see here the
number of questions asked for each field
here the duration you get to solve these
questions and the scoring
there is no pass Mark for each of these
tests so you don't have to reach for
instance 10 out of 20 minimum or 5 out
of 10 minimum no you just have to score
well
and the people scoring overall so the
combined score
who scores the best after this uh after
these three tests will be invited to the
next stage so your overall score the
three points combined should be among
the X best to make it to stage number
two
I really suggest you train these kind of
tests
um you can do so on our website you see
the link on the bottom of this slide
here which leads you to the sample test
page on our website
where you find sample tests in each
language available for these different
skills here
please train this because by doing this
regularly by training this you get
better at solving these questions you
get to feel the difficulty of the
questions
and also there's this time factor
involved you must be able to solve these
questions quite fast and by doing this
many times you get better at this
so as I said the one's best scoring will
be invited to the second stage which is
the assessment center and here firstly
we test a set of General competencies
you see the seven General competencies
listed here and we assess these
competencies through two tests there is
a case study to be done the case study
will test four of these competencies and
then there's a situational
competency-based interview which will
assess three more competencies
the case study is written a written
exercise and the situation of
competency-based interview is an
interview where you are put in a work
related situation
and we basically want to see how you
react in that situation
you sit both these tests in your second
language so the one you indicated in
your application when you register for
this competition either English or
French
and you see the scoring 10 points to be
one per competency and here you need a
again a combined pass score of at least
35 out of 70. so in principle you could
fail for one or more competencies as
long as you make up for them in the
other competencies and as long as you
reach at least 35 out of 70 combined
apart from the general competencies we
also test of course field related
competencies in one of these fields of
the competition and we do this through
an interview again in your second
language and scoring is up to 100 points
and you need at least 50 out of 100 so
really an important part of the
selection of course
the ones with the overall best scores in
the assessment center so both the field
rated competency and the general
competencies
are the successful candidates
and you see again the numbers here that
we need per field so in total about 101
and these people are listed on this list
of successful candidates which will then
be recruited by the different EU
institutions and bodies
um I would really advise you again to
read the notice of competition very
carefully because it will give you very
detailed information about the job
description about the eligibility
criteria and about these different
stages of the tests uh if you would have
more questions for us related to this
competition you can always reach out to
us through the web form on our website
you can easily contact us please do also
follow us on the different social media
look for EU careers and you will find us
and you can follow us and we will update
you on different opportunities to come
and work for us
so I hope you find this interesting
and I hope you will join this
competition because we need many people
in these fields as you can see and I
wish you all the best of luck through
your application and through the
different stages of the testing thank
you for your attention bye-bye